for someone with the name godzilla
mendoza i sure don't talk about godzilla
often
and when i do the guy who edits the best
of videos fast forwards through it
the godzilla anime how was that
not great okay so
people are left relatively unclear about
my thoughts and feelings on the
character
but the truth is i love godzilla
he's so versatile as a character and his
stories can range from very dark
allegorical horror films about real
world tragedies
japan has dealt with two family-friendly
comedy films with a silly tone
to action heavy films that turn him into
a sort of enormous superhero
and then something that's all of the
above somehow despite being a really
simple character with very little
personality beyond
smash and fight stuff you can do a
surprisingly diverse range of stories
with him
and with a roster of enemies and allies
as legendarily huge as
godzilla you'd think it'd be pretty easy
to make games about these titans
clashing and yet
it seemed to be kind of awkward in
execution for the longest time
people far more prolific and talented
than myself have covered the early era
of godzilla games but left out on a note
of
all the 3d games are probably better but
like
are they and well i guess we'll answer
that question today by taking a look
back at a handful of virtual colossus
bar fight simulators
it's nice and cathartic to sit back and
watch society break down and mass chaos
and panic happen because of something
silly like a giant lizard that fights
robots instead of like
something terrifyingly real and it goes
without saying you should protect
yourself and stay at home as much as you
can right now
but if you're like me you find yourself
on the internet more than ever in these
times
and that can be a dangerous place too
that's why i'm proud to announce that
this video is brought to you by our
gracious sponsor
nordvpn using nordvpn you can keep
yourself safe from any stray digital
kaiju that may come ashore in your
explorations online while researching an
inordinate amount of facts about the jfk
conspiracy theories
or which spider-man runs will most
effectively help you win an argument on
twitter
no judgments here we all use the
internet to argue and look up crazy
stuff
and now you can be safe from viruses
block intrusive ads
and double encrypt your own data so the
aliens can't steal your three terabytes
of cat pictures being that there's more
down time than ever now and we're all
stuck inside you're also assuredly
looking for entertainment wherever you
can get it
well nordvpn can help you access
geographically restricted servers so you
can get games earlier
check out a selection of streaming
platforms in different regions for a
whole new set of shows yo they have
ninja turtles on filipino netflix and
not in the us
well thanks nord i needed my fix no
wonder they're the top
rated vpn of 2019 especially compared to
my own software xavier's virus puncher
is coming in at about
789th place nord has apps that can
pretty much work on
any modern device faster connection
speeds handy google chrome plugins and
no
data logging to keep your internet usage
safe and private with a 30-day
money-back guarantee it's a no-brainer
to try it out and you can help support
me and my channel by using the promo
code
norvpn.com forward slash godzilla
mendoza
and getting a 70 discount while you're
at it give it a shot today
and while you do that i'll be battling a
few monsters in cyberspace on my own in
godzilla war of the gaming save the
earth monsters all-out attack
godzilla trademark save the earth
copyright on ps2
all rights reserve is an arcade style
fighting game with a unique challenge
ladder based on each playable monster
many challenges in between fights a
versus mode
and a survival mode it's developed by
pipeworks software
now renamed pipeworks studios and is a
sequel to their previous game godzilla
destroy all monsters
i'm assuming it's not much different
from destroy all monsters but i can't
play that one because it's like not
available
on any of the consoles i record with and
also getting things in the mail like an
ancient ps2 game is somewhat impossible
right now
but uh anyway save the earth i dig the
combat for the most part
as the characters feel clunky and slow
enough to get
some sense of their scale and strength
but when they move too quickly they
don't feel like
kaiju they feel more like normal sized
monsters and robots fighting in a small
city
you know something pacific rim uprising
didn't understand and that movie sucks
ass and killed the franchise and they
killed off the only likable character go
[ __ ] yourself there's a lot of moves
that
really throw off that sense of scale
like godzilla doing this silly ass roll
to get out of trouble when he's been
knocked down
i kinda like to imagine how much
destruction that would cause if he ever
really did that
the game's plot is a pretty utilitarian
single cutscene thing where cronica from
mortal kombat says she wants godzilla's
dna to do some villainy things and also
explain
pickups in game it feels like a single
cutscene intro you'd get before an
arcade rail
shooter at the movie theater that you
play with your friends god i miss going
outside there's a lot of quirky and
strange little things about this game
that i like
like this funny animation of godzilla
hurting his hand the legal disclaimer
health bars and the fact that this
godzilla is verbally referred to as
godzilla by characters in the game
for some reason the atari logo is one of
the in-game power-ups too
the enemy ai feels a little oblivious
and simple because you can beat this
game very quickly with no deaths on like
your first
try i don't know it's hard to give more
in-depth criticism of this game it's so
simple and basic it does just about
everything it needs to as this type of
game
you know like but it nothing more than
that
if anything i just wish it had more of a
story than like
nothing at all a unique ending for each
character would be nice
maybe a wider variety of arenas since a
lot of them are very
samey cityscapes i do think the roster
is pretty cool though
you got 90s godzilla 2000s godzilla even
though they're barely different
space godzilla mechagodzilla's
not ultraman but basically ultraman bug
guy with weird weapon hands
other bug guy with weird weapon hands
baby mothra
lady mothra meanie mothra that guy that
tried to eat godzilla like a [ __ ] boa
constrictor oh god that traumatized
me as a kid the destroyer and nobody's
favorite monsters
anguirus and baragon and the rest
i've never really made godzilla content
before so i wonder if it has a really
obnoxiously pedantic fanbase that don't
understand satire so they're going to
get mad at me for clearly
intentionally saying character's name
wrong as a joke well
see um his name is megalon get it right
you're a fake fan and a
virgin i i like how in this scenario
my knowledge of godzilla characters
names is tied to my ability to have sex
like
knowing more about godzilla would
somehow mean i can get laid
as opposed to the other way around like
in real life
this was the first godzilla game i ever
played and i have quite a few fond
memories of playing it with my dad as a
kid
it's pretty simple and basic with a few
strange x
eccentricities what the [ __ ] kind of
word is that
that make it unique but it's no
underrated hidden gem
classic if anything this feels a little
unpolished and unfinished which is
especially disappointing considering
it's
the sequel makes me wonder how stripped
down
and basic destroy all monsters must be
regardless it's not
terrible just not very deep and it might
be a fun time waster to play with your
friends while you're stuck inside
play it if you can find a copy for like
five dollars
scooby doo 2 godzilla unleashed more of
the same
better graphically worse functionally
they improved the textures in this game
but now it
slows down considerably when there's
more than one enemy fighter on the map
i know it's not some we slow down the
frame rate to make godzilla feel larger
kind of thing
because i've seen it speed up and slow
down in real time based on what's
happening in the fight
and it's generally not as bad when
there's only one opponent
i feel kind of like an idiot for asking
for a story with the last one because i
forgot something
it would have been a kaiju movie story
you know
boring elongated scenes of humans
sitting around
talking at desks about what's going on
in the world
you as the audience member completely
checking out until godzilla comes back
and assures you that explosions will
indeed happen at some point
some of these cutscenes last four whole
minutes
and say absolutely nothing of value the
story this time around is that a
mysterious crystal thingy from space has
crash-landed on earth and is causing the
weather to act like how it will if you
don't start recycling
godzilla goes on an erratic global
adventure to fight monster after monster
and smash crystals
all for the reveal that the crystals are
being generated by the final boss
space godzilla so so like a random
fighter from the previous game
is now a final boss despite not being
much tougher than he was before
that's some armageddon blaze [ __ ] look
if you want me to make more of those
videos then watch the previous two once
they hit 100k i'll do another one okay
all right please i work hard on them
oh i can't reenact that scene from that
movie
or that similar scene from that other
movie
witnesses say they also identified eric
lyncher at the scene who hasn't been
cited since
his controversial intervention at the
kennedy assassin the ai is now even
dimmer than before and sometimes forgets
to even
fight you obsidius doesn't give a [ __ ]
about this fight
i hit him and he just walks away come on
dude just like fight me please
please fight me
i godzilla i washed my hands
first please
and this boss fight with this stupid
drill rocket with ice lasers is so
tedious that i couldn't beat it in time
before the clock ran
out does it matter nope game still goes
on regardless a lot of these rounds end
for no reason at all
you can just walk around and like try to
get the busted ai senpai to notice you
for three minutes and then
it'll randomly decide you won and even
if you didn't win you still progress
anyway
sometimes i just let the enemies fight
each other while i sit back and watch
godzilla passive observer something
that's becoming
really clear in both of these games is
how annoyingly stiff the combat feels
and not in like a i'm a 10 000 ton
gigantic monster stiff in like uh this
is bad gameplay stiff there's not a lot
of great feedback in combat to make you
feel like you're actually doing damage
if i didn't have a health bar indicating
that any of this fighting
mattered i wouldn't have any sense that
i'm winning did they at least add
anything new to this one to justify the
three year development time
well we have a whole slew of new
characters like obsidious
apparently the wii version had more
characters but i can't record that
and i don't have a wii anymore so
man this is all godzilla's got going for
him in games
are there any good kaiju fighters on the
ps2
hmm that's not godzilla
but it's close enough that i can close
my eyes and pretend
rampage war on man if i didn't bundle
this in with something more
algorithmically marketable i'd never
have a chance to talk about it but this
game's
sick this game needs to stay at home for
14 days
this game's gotta check in and it's
shifted burger king because staying home
for two weeks isn't financially viable
right now with the rent is high
this game's so sick it's wow i really
hope these jokes are dated and not funny
in like a year because like
if if they're still relevant we have
some problems
war of the monsters is the somehow
superior great value brand of monster
action brawler with a timeless
50s b-movie aesthetic and just enough
story and cut scenes to understand [ __ ]
but not so much that you're bored and
want to sleep only to be awoken by
buildings tumbling down and quicksilver
screaming
aliens invade earth that's bad but we
defeat them with the power of tesla
coils
that's good but the power source from
the alien ships leaks into the
environment and creates giant monsters
that's bad but then we build giant
robots to fight them
that's good but the robots go rogue so
they're just as violent as the monsters
that's bad but then they fight that's
so the gameplay is a nice change of pace
because it's a lot less stiff
and clunky than pipe works godzilla
which may be partially helped by the
monsters being a bit
smaller than your typical kaiju more
like the size of the rampage monsters
and dwayne johnson versus the chicago
mafia or
whatever that movie i don't have the
expectation of these guys being bigger
because they're all
original characters quote unquote and
could be whatever size the game wants
i kind of wish this game got a
re-release wait this game got a ps4
re-release
well damn that's more than worth ten
dollars i'm not even finished with the
review and i'll tell you to go get it
it's awesome
weirdly enough the stylized almost
cartoony characters and environments
make the visuals pretty timeless
this still looks good even if it came
out in 2003.
it came out before save the earth and
godzilla unleashed and it looks and
plays better than both
somehow the gameplay has some of the
standard clunkiness expected from a ps2
game but
still feels pretty responsive once you
get used to it
you're never struggling to do basic
things like
you know jumping although the climbing
mechanic for buildings is a little hard
to do in the heat of combat and can be
frustrating at times but then you can
just play as a character who jumps
higher or flies to get on rooftops
you gotta love how it doesn't take 10
seconds to charge up a projectile attack
and unlike godzilla games you actually
get a sense that you're doing damage to
your opponent
and it doesn't feel like you're smacking
your hands against a brick wall
the enemy ai is also smart enough to
challenge you but not
so smart it's unfair when their health
is low they can use the same health and
energy pickups you can and will actively
seek them out
this forces you to strategize and try to
grab up all of that stuff yourself
before they can
oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] scigor it's short
for a cybernetic
gorilla in the combat ladder
this disagreement of the creatures
actually has unique boss fights that you
can't take on in the verses mode
and some nice little cut scenes to set
up each fight and give you some context
about what the enemy is going to be
without having any boring overlong
dialogue
look here's a robot and some tanks i can
assume this guy is with the military and
wants to knock my monster teeth out cool
let's fight
this nuclear generator blew up and now
this sugar-free biolante
has risen from the ashes to get punched
repeatedly
you see how simple that is godzilla
unleashed with your [ __ ] four minutes
of
that's not fair of this and hey you can
play with
four characters and the game doesn't
turn into dread too
i really dig the character designs in
this game and the roster has a pretty
diverse set of monsters and robots to
smash each other with
i think it's fun that they have an
american robot and a japanese one that
both feel
really like something from either
country's fiction
my favorite character has to be
kinetaclops the electric eyeball guy
who can do sick b-ball moves hell i'd
like some action figures of these guys
if those existed
i love how each character you beat the
game with gets a special cut scene to
explain their origin
if you have ten dollars and want a good
time get war of the monsters it's great
from top to bottom
it's about as short as these other games
probably shorter even
but it has great replay value in trying
to master every character
and getting all the unique cutscenes and
character outfits
alright i offset all the negativity with
something positive
let's keep that vibe going forward with
our last game on the list
okay think positive thoughts godzilla
godzilla released in 2015 after the
resurrection of the godzilla franchise
with the 2014 american reboot
this game is a tribute to godzilla's
long legacy and includes almost all of
his foes as well as arguably his three
most iconic designs by that point
2014 godzilla is even a dlc that you
that you uh you can't get anymore
because they took the entire game off
the marketplace
oh that's okay you can still unlock him
by getting to level 25 in the game's
main campaign
called god of destruction mode this is
the first game on our list that isn't a
traditional 3d brawler and is more about
slowly but surely waddling towards
enormous generators
then methodically punching them while a
very slow
energy shield powers up to slowly knock
you down so you can slowly get
back up to fight again
initially i liked how large and
lumbering godzilla feels to control on
this game you definitely get a sense of
the weight he's throwing around by
having to
turn his body with r1 and l1 buttons
feels like driving a tank almost but at
the same time it can get a little bit
frustrating when you need to get across
the map in a hurry because there are
time limits that's that's good design
for
a game where you're a big slow thing
that can't walk fast
oh would you look at that you can unlock
the final four missions of the campaign
without completing a very specific set
of side tasks along the way
that's um strange but okay
apparently you can unlock levels 21
through 24 by standing at these data
collection point things
and you need to get 50 percent of them
in every level
why not 100 percent you ask well just to
be different
what about unlocking other playable
characters well you can unlock them by
facing them in the story mode but
sometimes they spawn kind of randomly
like in the first level you can fight
jet jaguar by
getting 50 to 59 of the total structures
damaged and then
breaking the generator to complete the
level then
instead of the level ending he'll spawn
in for an optional boss fight
and the game gave you no indication of
how to unlock that and i had to look at
the strategy guide
online to even know any of this also you
may have noticed you can only unlock
levels 21 through 24 while 25 remains
locked up tight
that's because in addition to everything
else you need to do like getting 50
of the data collection points 100 of the
destruction levels
participating in strange summoning
rituals to get boss fights to happen
you also need to have grown to 100
meters in height you start the game at
50 meters tall and godzilla gets taller
the more destruction you cause but you
can't simply just smash all the
buildings you have to smash them very
quickly to get your rage multiplier to
boost your growth score but i said
earlier you can't walk very quickly so
it's difficult to smash everything in
the map in a timely manner while also
destroying three generators per map
fighting the random boss spawns getting
50 of all the data collection points and
completing side objects
like destroying six trucks in a
helicopter [ __ ] i just wanted to beat
the game why did they make it like this
why do basic things like unlocking
characters and getting to the final
levels of the game need to be played
like a goddamn puzzle for an obscure
easter egg
it shouldn't be this obtuse and
difficult to do how hard is it to just
put me in an arena say go kill that
monster over there and let me progress
once that's done
then just do that 25 times why do i need
to waddle these annoying ass generators
why do
i need to collect 50 percent of data on
godzilla for the stupid military to
fight me
the goal is to smash stuff as godzilla
why do i need to make it easier for the
military to fight me
isn't that counterintuitive to the whole
goal of being godzilla
why is it so hard to get godzilla right
in a 3d game
i don't think i'm asking for a lot when
i want the game to have
some actual content in it decent
performance that allows it to be
playable and feel like a goddamn game
instead of an elaborate escape room
where you have cinder blocks tied to
your ankles
and occasionally someone in a silly
costume will walk in and push you over
repeatedly
why is it that war of the monsters is
the only thing even remotely close to a
proper monster brawler and it's some
legally distinct off-brand copycat
the king of kaiju deserves better than
that man
imagine a modern game where you have
this huge roster of characters to play
with
a more polished version of like this
one's gameplay
and a level structure of unique bosses
like war of the monsters
i could take it or leave it but it would
even be cool to have a few story
segments where you play as a human
running around in the city trying to
survive
while a massive giant monster battle
happens right on top of you
that way you can get a real sense of the
scale and scope of these battles
something i feel like all of these games
brush up against but never really get
right
is the sense of scale godzilla himself
in these games
always feels like a regular sized
character
interacting with small objects and
environments
but a game should be more immersive than
that if it was done right you can feel
his presence in a way you never could in
a movie
you don't want to feel like an actor in
a rubber godzilla suit
waddling through a big plastic set you
want to feel like
a titanic monster carving a path through
immensely large
structures and so far that's been one of
the biggest disappointments of all the
godzilla games
i have faith though i think they'll get
it right eventually
just needs to take a few cues from what
they got right and wrong in the past and
push
forward how many stranger things have
happened i still remember a time when
someone said we'd never get a good
batman game
now we have like two and a half of them
so
the king of the war of the revenge of
the monsters will have his day in the
sun
too we've been slowly walking towards it
for a long time
you